ah don't be alarmed it is just a suit
this is not my real face and body an aim
spray school mascot by day by night I am
also school mascot so what's your major
no no I'm not a student but I am a major
science enthusiast you know if I get the
word out this movie can still be a big
hit it could be like a Haitian Django if
you say so Andre vignette oh hey hey hey
what is going on without going to
Zoolander's in the conference room your
microphone it's not on the button with
the picture of the microphone I'm a bill
in collagen just happened hello now we
can hear you but every we cannot see how
about now oh yes oh yeah I'm gonna learn
how where was it hahaha don't expect
much chit chat from capital cut his
tongue out years ago and no it wasn't
any sort of rescue if that's what you
mean we all fled on our own
for this
boy Amun division to the north rod
division in the center tar to the south
nope Seth in reserve which accosted Rena
strength in the center you should
concentrate yours on fighting sleeve the
generalship to me